When you start talking about the physical
world, people are like, "Ah, I can't do
anything about that, right?" So, they like
immediately tune out.
And the whole point of this book is
like, here are all the things that you
can do. You don't need to be designer,
you don't need to move a wall.
You know, you think of space is kind
of fixed, but it's really one of the
only things we can change, right?
You're not going to go back and change
your upbringing. You can't change your
genes.
You can't change all these things, but you
can change your physical
surroundings.
But I think that like the psychological
needs for the people who are in the
places almost come before.
And just to point out that like this
isn't about necessarily designing buildings.
It's it's more about like moving among the
like if we're not building designers, right?
We all get to choose our spaces all
the time to some extent, right?
I mean, you might have to go to
a certain office.
You might have, you know, you've got your
house, you can't just immediately sell it.
But, we have all these spaces that we
can move between, and so we actually do
have a lot of
say in these surroundings that we
put ourselves in.
Let's get into the three, right?
Because we've touched on agency.
So, these core needs
and the three core psychological needs
agency,
growth, and connection, right?
They studied people in nursing homes and
like the one group could modify their
spaces, one group couldn't modify their
spaces. And the group that then they came
back and checked on everybody in 18 months.
And the group that couldn't modify their
spaces, they're like
were they The group that could modify
their spaces were 50 per cent
more likely to still be alive.
I mean, so it's again, this isn't like
I'm not saying change your space and you're
going to live twice as long.
I'm just saying that like this is this
is the this is how
important this need is, right?
To feel like you have a say in
the world around you can be like a
life or death thing.
This feeds on itself, right?
So, you get a little bit of agency
in your house, and then now you
feel like, "Okay, maybe I can take some
agency in the world, right?" And this is
I'm not a
you know, psychotherapist, but I you know,
I understand that one thing that gets
prescribed to treat depression is like clean
up your kitchen or you know, rearrange a
room in your house.
And it's not because a rearranged room makes
you less depressed, it's because the act of,
you know, feeling like exerting control or
like feeling like you have a say over
part of your world,
that can spill over into other aspects of
your life.
Every company will have in the mission
statement something about you know, like
having that spirit right and we care about
our employees. We want them to take it
you know, we really that's the element of
a successful company but then like are the
spaces kind of reinforcing that message is a
is a question or are they working against
it right because if you say hey everybody's
equal everybody has agency.
We want to hear your ideas you like
stick certain employees in cubicles and
others in like nice corner offices and it's
like well, what's what are the spaces saying
about like how you know, how much you
know, control everybody actually does have
in the situation.
I heard you talk on one show where
you're saying
that
one particular
I think it was one particular office that
was saying oh you can use the conference
rooms
if you know, if they're free just use
them you can do your calling there but
the boss was always doing his calls in
there so people like on oh I'm not
going to use it because I don't know
if he wants it or not right?
Right yeah and effectively like just sealed
off the conference room for all
time because the boss would just like use
it half an hour a day but it
was like
so and I think you know, getting back
to like, what's the general principle here?
It's, you know, when you're to think about
how is your space showing agency, right?
Now, Annette said, "Some office layouts
invite conversations and others kill it.
What is the single most common and
damaging mistake organizations make in
designing workplaces and why is it so hard
to get right?
There you go."
I would say it's
the most common mistake is to jump to
some lesser priority before you think about
agency, growth and connection, right?
Whether it's thinking about the layout and
oh, do I want the open plan office
that's trendy in Silicon Valley or do I
want the, you know, closed private offices?
No, ask about those fundamental needs first
or maybe
it's, you know, skipping right to the paint
colors or the technology that's going to be
on the walls or whatever.
Start with agency, competence, and
connection. Of course, you're eventually
going to think about those other
other factors, but you need to
begin with the most important ones.
Whereas if you've got a team, you've just
assigned a project to a team, and you
can say, "Okay, here's your space for the
project, right? The conference room in the
you know, you can set it up how
however you think is best for this project."
Now, all of a sudden, you're giving agency,
right? Cuz the people have say in their
space, but you're also like forcing them to
think through like what's this project going
to entail? What space is best serving this
project?
she said sharing a space, time, and
interest,
you know, like say for example, you and
I now are kind of sharing same space,
same time, same interest.
And she said that when people do
that with other people,
it's a it's a friendship factory.
Yeah. She goes, "Because, you know, you're
in this kind of you're actually when she
often does a conference or a talk, she
starts by saying, 'Hello, thank you for
coming along. We're in a shared space,
shared time,
shared interest. This is a friendship
factory. I'd like you to turn to the
person beside you before we start and tell
them a bit about yourself.'"
Right, because then now you're getting the
interest tie. Yeah.
Correct. And I was thinking, you know,
do you think organizations should do more to
create friendship factories in this lonely
world we seem to be living in more
now? Definitely. I mean, it's happening
anyway, right? Like if you it's one of
these things that it's not like you can
choose to
it's happening whether you design it or
not, right? So, you might as well be
intentional about it.
I like this is one of the things
that's hilarious to me on college campuses,
right? It's like you we have graduation
coming up at the University of Virginia and
the people who go to the graduation parties
are inevitably like the people who live
together first year, right?
I mean, so like
all these students here, right?
And you know, it's such a dominant factor
like the spatial connections that it's like
college-long friendships and then they come
back for tailgating.
They're like still tailgating with the kids
who they lived
the same dorm hall with.
, which so it's powerful.
So, yeah, I think the companies can
yeah, try to try to make that happen.
I just think having worked in big companies
myself for such a long time
getting this right and it's doesn't cost
money. I agree with you.
So many people say, oh, well, we don't
have the budget to change the space.
You don't need loads of budget to put
a chair
by the side of the kitchen so people
can sit down or put a couch there.
Like it's not like or move a couch
that's somewhere else that's not working.
You know, often you see couches sitting in
the lobby where no one actually sits in
it, right? Bring it in, use it somewhere
else, right? It's so simple.
Or just like removing obstacles, right?
It could be you know, this is a
thing that's getting in the way of
collaboration. All you have to do is get
rid of it.
That's definitely free.
Yeah. I so agree.
Congratulations. Book is brilliant.
Now, here's a final quick 30-second
questions that we ask all of our guests.
We're all about being better at work.
What's the smallest possible change you
think our listeners could do to have an
impact and a better day at work tomorrow?
Smallest little thing they could do to
have a better day at work tomorrow.
Go someplace new in your working
environment.
That's a great one.
We haven't had that before.
I love that.